i think the gamestop phenomenon is the
greatest story of 2021. the gamestop
thing was shocking
for a variety of reasons
for one i didn't realize they were still
around gamestop is is a brick and mortar
retailer the blockbuster of the day a
great place to go get
video games use video games classic
things like if you're looking for
nintendo or sega something from the 90s
gamestop would have it the flailing
company starts to attract the attention
of a special shadowy breed on wall
street called short sellers
major hedge funds we're talking about
melvin capital we're talking about
citadel had taken a short position on
gamestop it's taking a bet on the fact
that the stock goes down in value what
the short sellers didn't count on were
the reddit rebels
reddit is a social media site that has
subgroups for
any topic you can imagine and one of
them wall street bets was a collection
of people who were
playing the game on wall street and they
were playing to win all of a sudden on
reddit everyone started buying up stock
january 12th the stock is trading at
around 19 bucks but this movement starts
to really take hold and next thing you
know by january 25th it's at 500
imagine you're working at gamestop
corporate it's going what it's doing
what all right and you just don't want
to move you don't want to rock the boat
how much will be worth now okay okay
okay
so this is a true david and goliath
financial story i mean the little guy is
getting on reddit and they're teaming up
and they're beating the big banks at
their own game not only did they move
the markets but they pulled the rug out
from under the institutional investors
melvin capital which started the year
with over 12 billion dollars ends the
month of january with about eight
billion dollars a four billion dollar
hit it's always great with someone with
a screen name like roaring kitty that
beats all the big hedge funds of wall
street you gotta love that
this erratic trading caused groups like
schwab and td ameritrade and robinhood
to suspend trading and somehow made it
look like they were protecting the
overlords it's like robin hood doing a
deal with the sheriff of nottingham when
they start restricting trading on
gamestop
everybody in the country condemns it
when aoc and ted cruz agree on something
that's one of the signs of the
apocalypse wall street's is a necessary
thing right and i don't i don't begrudge
them having their game
but if people learn the game and they're
gonna play too you can't penalize them
for playing and you certainly can't
penalize them for winning i think the
investor community understands that now
online traders they care they're paying
attention they understand what a short
squeeze is and nothing is safe hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else